[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres c'est la 29e
finale départementale du parcours
sportif et des épreuves athlétiques pour
les pompiers du sis de la réunion au
stade régional gaby folio à petite-île
350 participants venus des quatre coins
de l'île vont se mesurer sur sept
épreuves athlétiques
d'abord c'est un jour de fête un jour de
retrouvailles puisque tous les sportifs
du département et bien sûr sur le ce
très beau stade de petite île pour dives
alors pour des épreuves sportives qui
sont très traditionnelle chez nous le
disait prob et l'éthique et puis le
parcours le parcours du sapeur pompier
quitte à un parcours du combattant de
cinq ans
[Musique]
c'est avant tout un rassemblant sportif
où tous les sens tous les projets qu'ils
soient volontaires les professionnels
personnels administratifs et techniques
se retrouvent pour une journée atone et
tenter une journée sportive
ils sont huit danseurs tous en situation
de handicap à se rendre à bourges pour
la huitième édition du concours national
handidanse l'association sportive et
culturelle de la personne en situation
d'handicap défendra fièrement les
couleurs de la réunion
elle essaiera de faire mieux que l'année
dernière où les danseurs avaient
remporté deux médailles d'or et une
médaille d'argent
l'année dernière à québec
on adore aussi schoendorff hollywood je
sais avec les adhérents
il a cette année au bape entier avec un
autre groupe serait ségard cette fois ci
on ne va pas présenter ses liens et on a
choisi s il ya des pierres aux
événements là mais le thème c'est
l'invitation pays de la réunion à l'île
de la réunion de l'ama la main et damman
pays n'a soleil le temps d'une après
midi ces collégiens et c'est gramoune de
la résidence de retraite médicalisée de
sainte-clotilde ont dansé et chanté
ensemble
une rencontre intergénérationnelle
organisée par le conseil départemental
des jeunes pour la fête des mèches
basses est sûr que quand on vient ici on
prend conscience de beaucoup de choses
qui sont seuls quelques qui sont parfois
en fauteuil roulant qui voit la portant
de venir ici pour sortir un peu de chez
nous et de voir c'est quoi leur
quotidien le rapport cette bonne heure
c'est grandiose qui ce que j'ai vécu à
tuer comme moi aujourd'hui en tant que
représentant du département en tant que
main tant que maman c'est grandiose
parce que on voit l'amour de ces jeunes
et on voit l'amour de ses les nos aînés
qui qui attendent en fait est qu'ils
sont là et c'est magnifique
ses deux sauts des effets aux à
renouveler mais autant de fois pour le
souhaiterez parce que c'est ces jeux
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
une soirée au clair de lune pour ces
riverains de la rue hamelin a la
possession c'est de l'ambiance et de la
bonne humeur pour la fête des voisins
ils se sont tous réunis soit près de 150
personnes autour d'un bon repas et d'une
bonne dose d'animation la rue chopin
c'est la première fois qu'ils
chambre et on va on va faire des choses
comme il faut après il va y avoir un
karaoké mais karaoké pas d'excusés mais
par par groupe
donc un bébé il y aura le repas après
une grosse soirée dansante jusqu'à une
heure du matin
moment de convivialité et un moment de
rencontre et d'échangé parce que tout le
monde y amène chacun un petit quelque
chose et c'est le battage le tout le
monde mais en somme ce qui ce qu'il a de
mieux et moi j'ai envie de dire que
c'est cela aussi la réunion le mieux
vivre ensemble que je brode c'est cela
et la fête des voisins est un beau
symbole de notre vivre ensemble à la
réunion
le bonus de cette semaine c'est la bande
annonce du salon des seniors de la
réunion qui se déroulera le week-end du
1er 2 et 3 juin prochains
le département de la réunion vous invite
au salon des seniors réunion les 1er 2
et 3 juin pour permettre aux seniors de
la réunion d'obtenir un maximum
d'informations sur leurs droits pour
tout simplement bien vieillir besoin
d'informations sur l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie
le chèque santé le pass loisirs le pass
transport ou encore les maisons
d'accueil familial le stand du
département vous accueille de 9 heures à
18 heures au parc des expositions de
saint denis les 1er 2 et 3 juin 2018 le
département aux côtés des réunionnais
[Musique]